foreign
Houston what's up Anna
hi I'm doing okay how are you good go
Astros what's up
well I'm calling because
um I love your show and I've listened to
a lot of different things that have
helped me and
um I need some guidance here I really
feel like I'm I don't know what to do
right now let's do it let's do it let's
figure it out
so I don't know where or how to draw
boundaries for my own health around my
grandmother and helping her and
basically
providing all of her emotional and
physical needs I make nearly all of the
decisions in her life
um and it's making taking a major toll
on me emotionally physically I'm hyper
stressed all the time I can feel it in
my body
um I've had to I've started paying for
the very expensive yoga membership
because I have to find a way to like
calm myself
um I I'm just I'm hopeless at this point
um because I feel stuck
um where's your kids
okay um I'm her granddaughter so she
only had my mom and
my mom just passed away in September
actually geez I'm so sorry yeah
was that unexpected
well yeah um not not shocking but
unexpected in that we didn't expect it
to happen
um they this goes into that but her and
my mom both sort of had a drug problem
like prescription pills and
um I made peace with the fact years ago
that my mom was probably gonna go that
way and
um that's what we think happened
um my grandma actually found her they
lived together my mom was living with
her for the past six to seven years
and they were kind of enabling each
other in this addiction and a lot of
dysfunction
and so my grandma found her uh one
morning
and um so that's that's kind of where
we're at there's been a huge shift
obviously my mom was living with her for
the past six to seven years at least
being there in the house to make sure
she had meals my mom could cook a little
bit my mom could clean up a little bit
my mom was someone in the house to like
wake her up and
be aware if my grandmother fell or
looked like she might be not waking up
and maybe took too many pills and my mom
would call 9-1-1 it was sort of like a
safety valve there you know
and now my mom is gone
um as dysfunctional as that was and how
much stress my mom's addiction and my
grandma and everything and her addiction
caused everyone that's not there anymore
right and um I've been taking care of
like the financial responsibilities for
my grandmother
for a long time she kind of checked out
of it was unable to keep up with it when
I stepped in it turned out my mom was
stealing tens of thousands of dollars
from her over the years yeah yeah so um
what I'm going to say is going to sound
harsh okay
I want you to like know like you and I
are just hanging out okay so I'm talking
with you all right not at you
if your grandmother as an adult is an
adult who's struggling with addiction
is Gonna Act Like or is in a place where
she is acting like a child you are a
caretaker
you have to not be an enabler and you
have to be willing to make the hard
decisions that parents have to make for
their kids
what do I mean by that
you have to take an honest assessment of
her
um financial situation
and that may mean that you got to sell
her house and move her into a a living
facility because you've you've
acknowledged it you cannot control
I mean you don't have the skill set for
you're not you're not a stay-at-home
nurse you can't you're not living there
24 7 365 right you see what I'm saying
yes yeah I do I I don't have the skill
support for sure I don't have the
capacity and I don't have a skill set
the sort of sticker is that I can't make
her do any of those things you're
exactly right you know I can't force her
to sell her house she has the ability I
mean I don't have legal rights over that
she is she's with us she's a lucid
person if I were to take that to court I
don't have the money to make that happen
in court even if it would happen but
here's the deal
that means you have to make another hard
choice
choosing to
she at this I unders I've heard you say
this once do a caller that
um
someone in her family was treating her
like an anxiety Med every time they
picked up the phone and that show hit me
because that's what my grandma does like
times 10 for like all her stress her
problems yes she has just taken the the
dance she did with your mom
yeah and let's be very very honest this
is hard to say
I can't imagine a scenario
where a parent who is co-involved with a
kid in reciprocal drug use and support
that that relational dysfunction hasn't
happened for so long that Mom learned it
somewhere
right I'm not sure if I totally feel
like you mean the relationship between
my mother I'm saying there must have
been an issue between grandmother and
mother to where your mom said the best
way I can get through my day is by just
by checking out with drugs yeah my mom
had yes yes my mom had lots of problems
my grandmother had lots of problems
right and sometimes she was young your
grandmother lost her dance partner
and she just picked you up and said
let's go and you are dizzy from spinning
around so much right yes and so what you
have to say you've heard me say this on
the show a bunch you've got to let go of
Grandmother for a second
go over
punch the DJ in the nose
or unplug the DJ system
um Turn All the Lights On and look at
your grandmother and say I'm not dancing
with you
if you want to live
you wanna have a good life
I'm going to help you make those
decisions that way
if you want to have somebody that every
day you wake up and you just drag
through the mud
who is serving as your human Xanax that
you want to do drugs with I'm not that
person
[Applause]
three months or so I haven't really seen
that happening I think that was a
function of my mom being around a large
part of it I do think that um is yet to
tell but at this point that's kind of
what I'm seeing let me say let me say it
this way let me say this way
um propping up your grandmother will not
fix your relationship with your mom
okay
making trying to make right right now
doesn't heal that hole that's inside of
you
yeah I am definitely dealing with a lot
yeah I am dealing with my relationship
with my mom now that she's gone for sure
I'm yeah trying to come to terms with a
lot and I know that because you are
letting this Duty that you've created
for yourself pull you under water you're
gonna drown
I know but you're drowning trying to
save a ship that has no interest in
being saved
and but how do I do
I do needs help and care and we accept
your help and care
sometimes to a certain extent I want her
to get like a home
help can she afford that
you can we can make that work
um At first she didn't want to she said
it was too expensive
um so my friend my friend Henry clouds
and this is a harsh way he says it but
he's right
your grandmother's never had to get home
health nurse or have anything that she
didn't want because she always had
somebody there
to the way Henry says Dr Cloud says is
um he's usually talking about kids is
they got to get some problems
and at some point your grandmother has
to understand I love you and I will be
the the I'll be the uh the care manager
but I can't be the caretaker
so I will make sure that we have a good
contract with the home health nurse
company and that somebody's there and if
somebody doesn't show up you let me know
and I'll make that phone call I cannot
be your home health nurse
and so hear me say I can't come over
three times a week
and as an adult who's Lucid she gets to
make her decision well then I guess I'm
just gonna fall and die here by myself
and there are some adults that will make
that choice
and it's I feel like that's the choice
she's making it's heartbreaking
foreign but unless you want to go to
court and have her civil rights taken
away
drowning yourself in this sort of pseudo
hero thing isn't gonna isn't gonna help
anybody you both end up underwater
I do feel that sense of like people say
to me we'll just just stop or don't do
it you're hurting yourself and you can't
do it all and it's like I can't
imagine where I don't
thank you
feel responsible for her I just can't
imagine I will but you are a person just
by listening to your story you're a
person who either ORS everything
to have the most expensive yoga class or
I can't make it that's not right that's
that's a way you have chosen to justify
having a really rad yoga class and
that's great cool but there's there's
steps in between
either I go over there every day to make
sure she's not dead and she's taking her
medication or this whole thing that's
not true you can go every you can go
every Sunday I'm coming over for
breakfast every Sunday whether she wants
you there or not I'm coming over
and I'll listen to you complain away and
tell me all the things about great I'm
not going to be your emergency home
health nurse every time you call me I
was gonna call 9-1-1
and the moment you're ready for in-home
care I will be I'll be here to help set
that up you see so there's Middle Ground
between this I've got to be her
everything I've got to be doing things
that I'm not even qualified to be doing
like nursing things and medication
management all that stuff I'm not even
qualified to do that
it's either that or I just your friends
are like well you just gotta tell her
just to screw off she gotta do I mean
you can't do that either I get I get
what you're saying yeah
but at some point you have to say hey
grandmother I am over my head
I can't manage I want you to have the
best possible life in the last few years
of your life and it's exceeding my
ability to manage it
I I have expressed that to her
um instantly a lot you know very clearly
um yeah yeah of late becoming more clear
yeah because I'm figuring out more how
it's affecting me and her response is
sometimes like kind of like you said
like this very extreme either or like
well then I'll just take you off all the
accounts and you won't have to worry
about any of it and like kind of
manipulative that's right just acting
like a child that's right
if she takes you off she takes you off
and that will be heartbreaking and
you'll have to grieve it and it'll be so
sad and there's not a freaking thing you
can do about it
I'm afraid someone's gonna take
advantage of her if I'm not there they
will they will
but uh
you're creating scenarios that are never
gonna come or that might come down the
road if this happens and this happens
and that means this is gonna happen and
you are suffering them in the present
you're creating things down the road
that are gonna be issues
if this happens and this happens and
here's where someone's going to take
advantage of her and you're gonna have a
stroke
both are true
and so
here's what I'll communicate to you the
greatest gift you can give your
grandmother right now
is that you be well
that you have enough capacity to help
her the to the best of your ability
and that means you have to Define
capacity what do you need what do you
actually need and you have to Define
what help what help you can you can
offer
and fine I'll just take you off
everything well grandmother you can do
that you and I both know that that's
immature and that you're just throwing a
temper tantrum if that's what you choose
to do then yeah you're an adult you can
choose to do that I hope you won't
because I love you and you're my only
family I got left and I want to continue
to help out there's just limits to how I
can help
and I know that there are I mean
gosh there's nothing more painful than a
than people in our Lives who make
choices and we know that those choices
are hurting them and at the end of the
day we can do very little about it
but I do know that going to war with
yourself when your body is telling you
you can go no further and you're like no
I'm gonna keep going it's unsustainable
and then man you've heard me talk about
this you end up resenting the fact that
your grandmother exists at all
and that's not where any relationship
wants no one wants their relationship to
end up there
and so make it clear here's what I need
make it clear here's how far I'm willing
to go make it clear
Grandma I'm still going to show up on
this day but I can't keep coming these
day express your needs very very clearly
I would probably recommend writing them
down and handing them to her here is my
schedule when I start coming to visit
you
here's what I'm willing to do
and at the end of the day man
the things you can't control you're
gonna have to let go
you're gonna have to grieve the fact
that you haven't let it go and I'm sorry
you get brought into this dance here at
the very end and man the music is
already going going and
your grandma's got a way of dancing and
either she's gonna change in short order
or there's gonna be a mess down the road
I'll tell you this
she is the luckiest grandma on Earth to
have you as her granddaughter trying to
help out she's lucky to have you Anna
but make sure Anna is well in this
process